[Musique]
baroin
elles font partie de nos paysages et en
temps de sécheresse elle représente
l'une des solutions de sauvegarde du
monde agricole et notamment dans les
eaux
avec ce développement agricole des eaux
les 250 retenues collinaires
individuelles représente une des
solutions à l'irrigation
avec l'aide du département est aveugle
et de l'union européenne
on est arrivé à a disposé et dessert qui
se développe à une vitesse grand v et
que nous constatons qu aujourd'hui en
l'absence d'une eau d'irrigation en cas
de sécheresse ou serait la faillite de
toute une chaîne de production commune
du tampon
intel et capello à 2050 mètres sur les
pentes du volcan pour les amener donc à
1650 m le président du département le
concéder pas portal nous a suivis et
aujourd'hui on montre bien que le
devient une arme quoi terrasser la
sécheresse
nous n'avons pas d'autre solution que
celle la raison pour laquelle le
département de la réunion a signé avec
la commune du tampon un accord-cadre de
rénovation des retenues collinaires
individuel dégrader ainsi que
l'acquisition de réservoirs d'eau un
outil essentiel pour un monde agricole
contre 1 est fortement concurrencé le
tampon pilote la mise en place de cette
convention départementale et notamment
dans des lieux comme ici une antenne de
la chambre d'agriculture
ce que ça coûte extrêmement cher de
tenir tous qui dit la bâche
pour l'apiculteur ça revient cher sur
l'exploitation et puis peut-être aussi
bas il faudrait je veux dire essayer de
faire comprendre aussi aux gens aussi
aux agriculteurs de château entretenir
les espaces autour des retenues
c'est à dire ne pas laisser en friche et
tout ça pour que la friche ne tombe pas
justement cole qui a beaucoup que ça
tombe dans les retenues pour faire des
impacts dans les bâches et tout ça six
cent mille euros sont alloués à cette
aide avec un plafond de 50 mille euros
par retenues collinaires individuel un
dispositif du plan de relance qui se
matérialise par sa proximité et la
fluidité du montage des dossiers
une maîtrise d'ouvragé de la commune il
n'y a pas de solution tipp pour le
prolongation ce que l'on sait c'est que
d'une part le département était
fortement sur les grands périmètres
irrigués et les grands réseaux
hydrauliques ce c'est évidemment
extrêmement important sur un territoire
insulaire comme la réunion d'avoir dû
structurants d'avoir des gros réseau
d'avoir des grosses capacités de
stockage à l'heure actuelle c'est à peu
près 16 mille hectares irrigués sur 43
mille hectares de surface agricole utile
donc c'est déjà plus d'un tiers de la
surface qui irriguait grâce aux orages
départementaux mais ce n'est pas la
solution idoine pour tous les
territoires on s'aperçoit que dans les
eaux dans les secteurs enclave est isolé
on ne pourra pas amener des périmètres
irrigués des gros réseaux d'irrigation
comme on le fait sur le reste de l'île
donc le stockage semi collectifs ou
individuels est effectivement une des
solutions qui permet aux agriculteurs
d'avoir un stock d'eau l'agriculture se
modernise les territoires change
l'adaptation est aujourd'hui essentiel
pour accorder l'avenir
hier
[Musique]